[Música]
de Qué signo es en la astrología
occidental es una constelación
determinada por cuando cae su cumpleaños
en el calendario sin embargo según el
zodíaco chino ong
el animal asignado a su año de
nacimiento y de los muchos mitos que
explican los signos de los animales y su
disposición el más prevalente es el de
La gran carrera según la historia ID el
emperador de Jade rey de los cielos
quería encontrar una manera de medir el
tiempo y por eso organizó una carrera
los primeros 12 animales en cruzar el
río ganarían un lugar en el calendario
del zodíaco en el orden de llegada la
rata se quiso comenzar temprano pero de
camino al río se encontró con el caballo
El tigre y el buey como era pequeña y no
podía nadar muy bien pidió ayuda a los
animales más grandes el tigre y el
caballo se negaron el buey de buen
corazón aceptó llevar a la rata sin
embargo justo antes de llegar al otro
lado la rata saltó de la cabeza del buey
y se aseguró el primer puesto el buey
quedó en segundo lugar con el poderoso
tigre justo detrás de él El Conejo saltó
ágilmente por piedras y troncos y llegó
cuarto Luego llegó el dragón que podría
haber volado directamente al otro lado
pero se detuvo para ayudar a algunas
criaturas que había encontrado en el
camino después llegó el caballo a galope
por el río pero en el momento de llegar
la serpiente reptó hasta allí el caballo
asustado retrocedió Y permitió que la
serpiente quedara sexta el emperador de
Jade miró el río y vio a la oveja el
mono y el gallo sobre una balsa
cooperando para abrirse paso por unas
hierbas cuando llegaron el Trío acordó
dar el octavo lugar a la oveja por haber
sido la más alentadora y armoniosa de
ellos seguida por el mono y el gallo
después llegó el perro luchando hasta la
orilla era un gran nadador pero jugueteó
tanto en el agua que llegó un décimo el
último puesto lo reivindicó el cerdo que
tuvo hambre y se detuvo a comer y a
echar la siesta antes de atravesar la
línea de llegada y así cada año se
asocia con uno de los animales en este
orden cuyo ciclo empieza de nuevo cada
60 años porque 60 y no 12 bueno el
calendario chino tradicional se compone
de dos sistemas superpuestos los
animales del zodíaco están asociados con
lo que se llaman las 12 ramas terrestres
o share otros sistema los 10 tallos
celestiales o tengan está vinculado a
los cinco elementos clásicos metal Jean
madera mu agua
y tierra tú a cada elemento se le asigna
gin o yang que crea un ciclo de 10 años
cuando los 12 animales de las ramas
terrestres se corresponden con los cinco
elementos más el yin o yang de las ramas
celestiales crea 60 años de
combinaciones diferentes conocido como
ciclo sexagenario o kanji así alguien
nacido en 1980 tendrá el signo yang
metal mono mientras que alguien nacido
en 2007 será Jim fuego cerdo también
puede tener un animal interno basado en
el mes de su nacimiento un verdadero
animal basado en su fecha de nacimiento
y un animal secreto basado en la hora de
su nacimiento fue la carrera lo que
determinó Qué animales ingresaban al
zodíaco chino Pero a medida que se
propagaba por Asia otras culturas
hicieron cambios para reflejar sus
comunidades Así que si consulta el
zodíaco vietnamita puede descubrir que
es gato no conejo Y si está en Tailandia
una serpiente mítica llamada naga
sustituye al dragón Así que si coincide
o no lo que dice el Zodiaco sobre usted
lo que es cierto es que revela mucho de
la cultura de donde proviene
conozca con este video La Leyenda China
de la serpiente Blanca inmortal su
verdadero amor y el monje que estaba
decidido a interponerse entre ellos
[Música]